network executives are paid to make the
tough decisions and sometimes are also
paid to make weird and bizarre decisions
like canceling your favorite show for no
apparent reason if you ever thought show
business made sense well think again
here's a look at the dumb reasons these
TV shows were canceled police squad
goals lots of movies are made out of TV
shows but the three naked gun movies
probably mark the first time a
successful series of films respond from
an incredibly unpopular TV show
nice Bieber thank you I just had a stuff
that may help you with that filled with
sight gags and reoccurring jokes police
squad starring Leslie Nielsen as
lieutenant Frank Drebin hit the airwaves
in 1982 and was pulled after just four
episodes with the remaining two burned
off over the summer
ABC president Tony Thermopolis was
surprisingly frank about why people
weren't tuning in he told a reporter
that quote the viewer had to watch it to
appreciate it that's right police squad
asked that its audience tried the crazy
thing where they pay attention to what's
happening on the screen
apparently the joke's on ABC's hit shows
Happy Days and The Love Boat were so
simple they could be understood by
osmosis
long in the tooth pulling in roughly
three to five million viewers per week
longmeyer was Annie's most watched
original drama ever and was among the
top rated dramas on cable TV during its
three season run yet the network
canceled it anyway why because most of
those fans were too damn old yes TV
networks are pretty much only interested
in courting the key 18 to 49 demographic
which advertisers think is the easiest
group to part from their money
so because Longmire's audience wasn't
gullible enough Annie
cancelled it no worries though the show
was picked up by Netflix which doesn't
have to worry about advertising trends
to rule for primetime during the 1969
1970 TV season CBS chief of programming
Fred Silverman noticed that the show's
getting the best advertising rates were
ABC and NBC shows aimed at young and hip
viewers with multicultural casts in
urban environments CBS's shows on the
other hand were mostly rural family
shows Silverman solution canceled all
his farm shows and replace them with
cutting-edge new city sitcoms out went
the Red Skelton Show Petticoat Junction
Green Acres lassie and the Jim Nabors
our replacing them honest-to-goodness
classics including The Mary Tyler Moore
Show all in the family
good times mod and the Bob Newhart show
ratings surged among younger
demographics and Silverman's move became
Hollywood legend known ever after as the
great rule purge the wrong kind of smart
for 26 years levar Burton's beloved
Reading Rainbow helped kids develop a
love of reading but in 2009 budget
restrictions forced the show's
cancellation because it wasn't educating
kids in a government-approved fashion
weird right well it all started with the
No Child Left Behind Act signed into law
in 2002 it sought to establish new
educational benchmarks for American kids
many of which would be measured with
standardized test results and at boxes
the bill I don't intend to read it all
that's fine for quantifiable skills but
it's hard to measure love of reading on
a standardized test so there went the
funding but hope is not lost thanks to
an incredibly successful Kickstarter
campaign Reading Rainbow is poised for a
21st century comeback I am overwhelmed
thank you so much this is going to
enable us to really really really do a
lot of good thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which cancelled show you think
should be brought back